Samad Sarmad about to bring you up on
stage man. Samad.
>> Hey guys, can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Peace upon those who follow the
right path.
>> So, thank you.
>> Uh, who should I start with? Is it going
to be the Arabic speaking lady or you
got logic? But I want to speak to one
person at a time. Yeah. I mean, you
start with me.
>> I don't want to be, you know,
>> you should start. You're already off on
the wrong foot, Summit, because you
don't get to dictate who you talk to and
who gets to talk.
>> That's fine. That's fine. That's fine.
Uh, God logic. Uh, do you want to start
or should
>> I would love to I would love to talk to
you sur if
>> Okay, go ahead. Go ahead, bro.
>> I appreciate it. So, um um I the way I
read the Quran, I look at verses, it
looks like plainly Allah is telling us
that the previous scriptures are the
authority over the Quran. What are your
thoughts?
>> Previous scriptures are the authority of
over the Quran and you get that from the
Quran itself.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay, make your case. So we have verses
uh like chapter 10 verse 94 and it tells
Muhammad what to do.
>> Just let me let just hold on a second
because I don't remember the numbers of
the of the of the suras
>> for unice.
>> You either tell me the name of the surah
or wait just two seconds for me to look
it up so that I know in which context.
>> I just told I just can you hear me?
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I can. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Surunas.
>> Surahunas. Yeah. Okay. Go ahead.
>> Verse 94.
>> Yes, sir.
>> All right. It says, "If you are in
doubt," talking to Muhammad, Allah is
speaking to Muhammad. "If you are in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you, then go and ask those who have
been reading the scripture before you.
Truly the truth has come to you from
your Lord. So be not of those who
doubt." So here Allah tells Muhammad
what he can do in the case that he
doubts what the Quran is saying. Allah
tells him if he's doubting what the
Quran is saying, you can go check the
previous scriptures to clear up your
doubts.
>> Yeah. And so this means that the
previous scriptures are the decisive
authority on which on whether or not the
Quran is telling the truth or not.
>> If the Quran is in line with what the
previous scriptures say, the Quran is
good. It's telling the truth. If it's
out of line, if it contradicts what the
previous scriptures say, then the Quran
is wrong and not from Allah.
>> Right? So that's your own ex Jesus of of
>> That's just what the text says.
>> That's an ex Jesus of the verse.
Actually, it doesn't mean that.
>> Yeah. Sure. Yeah. And that
>> should I speak to the Arabic speaking
lady?
>> You're talking to me, right?
>> No.
>> Uh because it need I need somebody who
speaks Arabic so that I can hear you
talking about
>> you can speak to me. You can speak to
me.
>> Okay. Do you speak Arabic? That's my
question.
>> Do do you have a I don't speak Arabic.
Do you have
>> Okay. So
really quick, just really quick. Do you
have a response? One second. Your grace.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Forgive me. Your grace. Um
>> do you have a response to what I said? I
do. That's what I was trying to tell
you. So, let me educate you on how to
understand the text from the Arabic
language itself.
>> Okay. So, Bri, go ahead. Go ahead and
break down the verse for me.
>> Yes, sir. I'm going to break down the
Arabic in detail
>> in the verse.
>> In the verse, of course. I'm not going
anywhere else unless I'm making a claim
and I would like to substantiate that
claim with something from the language
going to other sources. Say, for
example, poetry. Uh, we could go to
other hadith to other
>> 1094. Give me give me
>> 1094. 1094.
>> Give me the proper ex Jesus on 1094,
please.
>> That's not ex Jesus. That's the the
textual understanding, the linguistic
understanding.
>> Exesus.
>> That's ex Jesus.
>> That's not That's not ex Jesus. I'm not
>> There's nothing wrong with Jesus.
>> No, no, no. I'm not explaining the
verse. Let me let me let me just hold
with me for 10 30 seconds and I'll make
my case. You're not explaining
>> the if the if there the if there. Yeah.
That's not for possible conditions.
That's number one. So, and I could go on
a ranting and tell you why. Sorry.
>> It's not possible for Muhammad to doubt.
>> It's not possible for him to doubt. Yes,
sir.
>> Okay. What if he does doubt? What is he
supposed to do?
>> It's not It's impossible for him to
doubt.
>> Why did he try to pull himself?
>> It is an impossible condition. It is
>> Why did he try to jump off a cliff?
>> That's fine.
>> It is an impossible condition. That's
not that's not actually authentic
hadith. That's called
>> Guys, we're gonna go somewhere else.
>> So when he wanted to jump from the
cliff, that's not even
>> in Bkari. It's in Bkari.
>> That's not in Bkari in the corpus.
That's what are you talking about?
>> It is in Bkari.
Understand what I'm telling you is the
person, the narrator of the hadith,
yeah, is called Zuri. Yeah. And then he
says after he mentions the hadith about
the the revelation or the angel Gabriel
uh peace be upon him not coming to the
prophet for 40 days and then he says so
they they they call it
which means that this is what thought
but it is not within the corpus of the
itself. Okay. So that's that's cleared
out. No, no, no. You can't. Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, no, no. Hey, hey, hey, hey. Do not
be talking to her like that, man.
>> We lit we literally started off.
>> We literally started off by saying that
you you don't uh you don't dictate to to
people. And she says, "Hey, can I ask
you a question?" No, you cannot. Well,
if we're just going to if we're just
going to shout rules and uh be quiet or
something like that, what do you think a
discussion is? Come on. Yeah. Don't act.
Uh yeah, we we know what your religion
teaches about women, but uh don't act
like that here.
>> So DLC, you wanted to ask you wanted to
ask a question to Smad.
>> Yes. Is
>> hang on a second. Okay. Before you go,
>> no. No. No. Yo, both before you go.
>> Let me explain my platform. All right.
Go ahead.
>> All in one time.
>> Go ahead.
>> Speak one time. We take it one at a
time.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Explain.
>> I'm here. I'm here. I'm not running
anyway. I'm Go ahead. Go ahead. Go
ahead. All right. So, so back to that.
>> Take care of yourself. Watch your head.
>> In the audience.
>> Oh, man. I wanted to get him.
>> So did I.
>> But you know what, guys? That that's
like a typical Muslim culture. As soon
as a woman starts speaking,
>> do not marry into them until they come
to the Lord Jesus. I'm telling you now,
especially if from the Arab culture. I
don't care. I'm allowed because I'm one
of them.
>> Until they come to the Lord Jesus, this
is how they will treat you at home. if
not with the miswork if you if you catch
Madrid
>> and like notice Avery you you explained
1090 form very clear he said you're
wrong but instead of actually just oh
here here's why you're wrong a boom we
got this rabbit trail we got deflection
like this if we are wrong and how we
understand 1094 it should be very simple
we look how easy it was for you to
explain that then when we wanted him to
respond what happened big big big
kurfuffle of nonsense that we weren't
actually even getting he said well let
me explain I need to talk to the Arabic
let me talk about the Arabic No, no, no.
Just explain.
>> And then when I tried, they wouldn't let
me speak.
>> Yeah.
>> You wouldn't let and then and then he
just declares. He just declares with no
evidence at all. It's impossible for
Muhammad to doubt. Well, why would it be
impossible for Muhammad to doubt? And if
it's impossible for Muhammad to doubt,
why is Allah saying, "Hey, if you are in
doubt," and then when we bring out, wait
a minute, this guy, this guy doubted so
much that he thought he was possessed
and tried to hurl himself off a cliff or
uh he thought he thought uh he thought
later on he thought Allah was rejecting
him and so he tries to hurl himself off
a cliff. It seems to have doubts and oh,
you can't trust it. Can't trust Iban
Assad. Can't trust Ebanad. Can't trust
Bkari. He can't trust any of it. We
throw all that out. Okay, then what are
we basing it on? If your sources are
garbage and can't be trusted because
it's all madeup nonsense.
>> You can't claim that Muhammad couldn't
doubt because your sources that you
would base that on are all garbage and
you can't be tr and can't be trusted.
It's just a weird situation. I have I
have to I'll be right back. I have a I
have a phone call at 7. So, uh it's
short. It's short. Just got to call and
confirm something.
>> What's the point of Surah 1094? Like
what's the whole point of that verse?
The verse should just be like we know
Muhammad cannot doubt. Next verse. Like
instead there's this whole big
explanation. If you're doubting here's
what you're supposed to do. We're being
told Muhammad couldn't doubt. So there's
a useless verse in the Quran then
apparent.
>> Yeah. is completely. Not only that,
there are other verses in the Quran like
you pointed out, God logic, where
Muhammad is told to ask the people of
the book for things
>> which you know, how can we how are we
not authoritative or how is our
scripture not authoritative if what
those people at the time in the seventh
century told Muhammad was not legit? The
Quran says it's legit. He says, "Yeah,
go ask those people."
>> He lied about the Arabic. He said the
word if means it's impossible. That's
not true. We have tons of examples in
the Quran where it says the same exact
wording.
>> Yeah. For example, surah, that's what I
was going to get him at. Surah 94:5,
surely with hardship comes ease. This
this but we're talking
for example.
So if they stop, if they stop, sorry,
this is the one that I wanted, not the
previous one. If they stop, then Allah
will be meaning their sin. Allah will be
merciful. And also it says
surah 5:23
meaning depend on Allah if you are
believing.
>> So does that mean this impossible for
you to believe?
>> Exactly. This whole impossibility thing
is complete nonsense from hell. There's
no such thing as if impossible.
>> You can go to chapter 5
>> 5 verse 23.
>> Yeah. 5 vers 23. It's got the same in
the at the very end of the in the very
beginning.
>> All right. And then
>> there's no such thing as that word in
Arabic meaning is an impossibility. It's
a bunch of nonsense. And I was going to
show him and you know embarrass him, but
sadly he left.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, he he he found his way out.
>> There's no such thing as the word if in
Arabic means impossibility. Just the
same in English. Would you accept that
if someone says to you the word if means
the possibility is impossible?
>> He think he he thinks because it's
raising a conditional. It's a
conditional that means it's an
impossibility.
>> It's not impossible. It is a
conditional.
>> That's the miracle guys. That's the
miracle.
>> If I said it arrogantly and confidently,
it must be true.
>> It must be true. You see it?
>> And also,
sorry.
>> Go ahead. I'm listening.
>> Surah 2 verse 192. If they seize,
meaning if they stop, surely Allah is
all forgiving and merciful. Again, if
they do it, Allah will do this. That
means it's possible.
>> Yo, Avery, real quick. I got to go in
like a half hour.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Okay.
>> I I I do as well because I have a live
stream at 8.
>> What? What? Whatever. I I don't I don't
care, guys. Whatever.
>> Malam, how you doing?
>> We're just saying you don't You're not
the only
>> Doing well. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Okay, David, I get it. Um, hey,
Micham. What's up, man?
>> I'm doing very well. Just listening,
taking it all in.
>> Taking all in. You're a Muslim?
>> Yes, I am.
>> What do you What do you think so far? I
think the Quran is and the Torah are
great examples to show that when the
Gentiles try to read and study the the
scriptures that were delivered to the
children of Israel, they are totally
confused.
>> Okay. What about the
>> children of Israel? When they are not in
their scripture, the Torah and the pro
the scriptures that were delivered to
them in their language, that is the key
indicator that identifies anything that
has to do with possession of the
children by the children of Israel of
the word of God. It is it is going to be
in their language, not the language of
the Gentiles.
>> Let me ask you ahead this really quick.
Do you do you believe the Quran when it
says that Muhammad is mentioned in the
Torah and the Gospel?
>> The Torah? Yes. Not the Gospel.
>> Oh wow.
>> Wow.
>> So the Quran is wrong.
>> Yeah. Let me tell you why they're
reacting like this. They're reacting
like this.
>> You are wrong by implying that the Quran
is referring to the Greek gospels in any
type of way.
>> What is the word inje? The word in jail
is a term that is only going to be
understood and and practiced by the
children of Israel.
>> What is what is the the word what is the
word in jail? Is it an animal?
>> Uh the word injil uh comes from the root
word for the children of Israel that
means to rejoice.
>> No no it it's a transliterated word of
engon which is a Greek word. So Jesus
was given a Greek. Okay. If if you can
if that's what you want to believe.
>> No, that's what
Gabriel Reynolds.
>> Let's go to Let's go to Strong's Hebrew
1,500. We're
>> not talking about the Strong's Hebrew,
brother. Please. I want you to
understand the point. I want you
>> I want you to understand you only get
the word in jail. It mash the word in
jail is not an Arabic word. It deres it
a Hebrew Greek literally.
>> No.
>> No. It is. It is a Hebrew word.
>> Not a Hebrew word.
>> No, it is. Yes, it is. See, I mean, see
that's Wait, wait. Uh,
>> that's your input. Let's go to 1094 and
we can prove it.
>> Hold on. Mushalam, are you are you one
of these children of Israel?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Oh, is is is Avery uh children of
Israel?
>> I believe so.
>> Oh, okay. Okay.
>> Scattered in captivity.
>> Wait, is inspiring philosophy of
children of Israel?
>> Inspiring philosophy. this guy, the
white guy.
>> If he if he can claim that he descends
from a people that were scattered
through captivity, that he has lost his
heritage, that he has lost his name, his
way of culture, and it has been replaced
by his captures, and he has and he is
currently facing the enormous amount of
persecution, wrath by those. Wait,
there's a Hebrew. Those people cannot
take that from him. It's a muzz.
>> Yes. Our people come in different
>> the children of Israel.
>> It's a mus light.
>> So this person should be able to show
you Muslim.
>> Let's go to
>> What about Chris? Is Chris a child of
Israel?
>> If he does not fit that that criteria,
he's not amongst the children of Israel.
If his if his descendants are the
captors and the oppressors, then he is
not the children of Isra. What if what
if his ancestors were captives by
somebody else?
>> If they have to fit all the description
of the children of Israel that they are
currently facing the enormous amount of
humiliation, they are a terror and a
horror to all to many nations.
>> That they are that they are hated by
many nations
>> and that the children of Israel that
they're going to be hated. They're going
to they're going to be like a terror and
a her
and they're in those many nations
because they've been scattered.
>> She's a children of Israel. That's
crazy.
>> Also, one indicator is that their their
capttors are going to give them
worthless false gods and worthless
rituals such as cutting down a tree
>> with a
radio and gold. Just as
>> you're talking about Jeremiah 10, which
is about crafting idols. No scholar on
planet earth has ever interpreted
anything other than crafting an idol.
>> Avery, get that description.
>> I I IP inspired philosophy fits that
description perfect. Okay. That's why I
don't I don't take it. I I don't take it
from anyone. If if you claim to fit that
description, that is your identity.
>> So, do you fit that description?
>> Yeah. I think you're an Israelite, man.
>> Yes.
>> All right. Woo.
>> So, are you So, you a terror.
>> Well, let's be clear.
>> People look like me are hated wherever I
go.
>> Let me show you how inspiring
philosophy.
>> There are families who tell their
children.
>> I'm gonna show you how he fits the bill.
Look, listen. Inspiring philosophy. His
name is Mike Jones. Ask me who?
>> Who?
>> Mike Jones.
>> Mike Jones. Okay, let me tell you what
happens with this guy. Whenever he tries
to contact one of them Ishelites, one of
them one of them some of among them
Ishmaelite nations, them the Muslims,
the Mus. They either get a two, they
either
uh
>> oh
>> they get
>> see see even Avery's connection gets
messed up when he starts talking about
him.
>> You see what you get for getting an
Airbnb and not knowing what the
internet's going to be like.
>> Mhm. So powerful. My Anything you talk
about it causes problems. You might get
a toothache. Be careful. Muslim.
>> Yeah. Y'all get the picture though.
>> No, we didn't frozen.
>> You were totally frozen the whole time.
>> Yeah. Yeah. All we got was a picture.
That's all we got.
>> That's that's the effect of IP that even
the internet fears him. You know, that's
how much terror he inflicts. So, let me
just ask you this real quick. Uh, Malam,
where do you believe Muhammad is
mentioned in the Torah?
>> I believe he is mentioned in Deuteronomy
>> 18:15 or 18:18. Which verse? 185 through
19. He is the prophet that fulfills the
prophecy that he 1850 that he delivered.
Hold on. Before you guys go into that
real quick,
>> the word of God in like the similarity
to what was delivered by Prophet Moses
>> Musham. Hold on before you guys go into
that real quick. Do you believe that
Muhammad was a so-called black man?
>> What color was he?
>> I believe he was a descendant of
Abraham, a descendant of Ish.
I believe he had not of Caucasian.
>> He's a He's a descendant of the Brady
Bunch according to descriptions.
>> Yeah,
>> he was not He was not of Caucasian. That
was the whitest dude in the history of
humanity.
>> Can I Can I read that?
>> Let me let me go let me let me let me go
ahead and say it. Let me go and say it
right now. Muhammad was so white he
makes Wesley Huff look like Wesley
Snipes. So I'm just going to say
>> white supremacy though.
>> Oh
wow.
>> Yes. It's it's changed everything to
being white
exist.
>> Okay. Yeah. You guys go back to Jeremy.
>> But before we go there, let's go to I
mean let's
>> early Muslims. Let's go to Deuteronomy
18. I want to go to Deuteronomy 18. You
mentioned Deuteronomy 18. I just want to
read it. Can I just read? I want to read
it.
>> Let me read it. Let me read the verses
and 94. But
>> I would like to read. Okay. So, I'm
going to start. You said I could start
in verse 15. So, I'm going to start in
verse 15. So, this is about Moses
raising up a prophet. The Lord your God
will raise up for you a prophet like me
from among you,
from your brothers. It is him you shall
listen. So very clearly the prophet that
Moses is talking about has to come from
Israel because he says it is from among
you when he's speaking to Israel. Then
he uses this phrase from your brothers
which is used throughout Deuteronomy to
refer to Israelites. So whoever this
prophet is he has to be an Israelite.
>> Are you done?
>> Unless mom is an Israelite. You believe
that?
>> Now you as as I believe that you are a
G. So you will you cannot tell me that
instead of my brethren are going to
absolutely my language.
>> We just agreed that he is an Israelite.
We just agreed with that.
>> He descends from Ishmail.
>> No, I have native Israelite.
>> I'm We already agreed that. Yeah. Yeah.
We already
if you truly if Okay. Okay. So if we are
sitting there now, first thing first,
>> this prophet that is described in this
prophecy is going to deliver something
that is in similarity to what was given
to prophet Moses.
>> Does he have to be Israel?
>> And it is going to be in a language that
the children of Israel can understand so
that they can fulfill the requirement
because the requirement is that they
must hear and obey. So it must be in a
language saying that this must be an
Israelite. Can you deal
>> directly? But this is going to
disqualify the Greek. So you cannot say
that this is the New Testament.
>> Go ahead and watch your clip back,
man.
>> Watch your head, man. Get off my
freaking
>> You debunk it by just reading. And what
does he do?
>> Yeah, he's uh he's crazy.
>> Is that everyone's first time meeting a
Hebrew Israelite Muslim? That was my
>> No, that was interesting. And then he's
like and then he's like he's like my
people will understand my language. And
and Abram was like well here's my
language block.
>> So did Muhammad don't know Hebrew or
what?
>> Muhammad knew Hebrew. Hebrew. He knew
>> and he was a Gentile or Israelite.
>> He was both. See?
>> Oh wow.
>> He's whatever anyone needs to be. He's
like that man.
>> The the nothing in Deuteronomy 18 says
this prophet has to deliver it in a
language that the Israelites understand.
He made that up. It just says the
prophet has to be an Israelite and will
be like Moses.
>> First of all, you're not you're not
gonna accuse your fellow Israelite
brother of making stuff.
>> That's true. I apologize for that.
>> Right. I appreciate that apology. All
right. Listen,
>> he was he was funny. He was
>> and I appreciate you know he's
interesting. is funny.